I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and this hour,
well the honeymoon's over at Galapagos,
this is the place where Darwin began to
develop his theory of evolution and it's
the place 170 year or maybe 180 years
later where our producer Tim Howard landed
wearing fishnets and a bad
brains tee shirt like to find,
to find a very different
landscape than what Darwin saw.
And we just told you a story about how
far humans are willing to go to protect
something. This next part,
it's about how far we're willing to go
to get something back that we've already
lost to sort of restore a place and
a creature to its quote, wild state.
This story unfolds on one of Galapagos
is most northern islands where they also
had to get rid of some goats.
It's called Pinta. Pinta is,
was a very special place.
This is James Gibbs,
professor of conservation biology
at the State University of New York.
It's one of those islands. It's not
part of any tourist visitation site.
So there are no people there. And,
uh, when you set foot first on Pinto,
you immediately sense sure.
[inaudible] birds,
the problem is on a, things
were spinning out of control,
the vegetation was growing wild,
the forest was getting overgrown with
the wrong kind of plant and the whole
ecosystem was just
teetering out of balance.
And one of the reasons for this according
to Linda Coyote is that we had an
island with no tortoises
because tortoises are,
are sort of like the lawnmowers, you
know, they, they plow down vegetation,
disperse seeds, but for centuries
had been hunted by those whalers.
And in about 1906, the
pinto tortoise went extinct.
1906, yeah. Little over a hundred years
ago. They don't know the exact date,
but then one evening in March of 1972,
Oh yes, this fellow, she h he's
a well known tortoise researcher.
He was on Santa Cruz island having
dinner with some friends on regard to
chattering about tours. And one of the
people he's eating with says, Hey, uh,
I was recently on Pinna island
collecting snails and I saw this tortoise
and I thought, do you know what you
have done the readout for this is
the f a hundred years
he and some national park
rangers race out to Pinta
and there it was this beautiful
children, one male tortoise,
maybe 50 years old. They weren't
sure they'd eventually named Him
George Lonesome George. But at the time
the immediate question was of any mole
because if they could find a female
for George, then they could, you know,
maybe d extinct the species.
So they poked around in the areas where
we got the one and I found a shell of a
female dead animal. Yeah.
Well how had, how had
this female tort died?
Uh, someone chopped it in half. No, see
the marks where it was just chopped up.
I felt violent. I wanted
to borrow someone's gun.
I'd gone kill the person.
Everyone held out hopes for just
finding more tortoises back.
James says they kept going back,
combing the island with highly
trained tortoise, sniffing dogs.
But in the end there was just,
George then shifted the focus on,
now what do we do?
We then went to a wolf volcano island
next door and collected two females,
two females that sort of looked like
George but weren't quite the same species.
And we put them with George to
see if we could get him to breed.
He never did, wasn't interested,
so they thought, hmm,
maybe he needs a pinto lady.
So now of course there are no female
tortoises on Pinto, but they thought,
you know, maybe a zoo somewhere
or private collection has on,
cause you really never know. So they
called around, offered huge cash rewards.
People sent in dozens of tortoises.
But Linda took one look at them
and was like, no, no, no, no,
they weren't Pintos. So then they thought,
we've got to take matters
into our own hands.
Basically what you do is you sit at the
back of the tortoise and first you have
to get to where they'll
allow you to touch them. Um,
and eventually you start, um, you know,
fondling their, their legs and tails and,
and hoping to get them to ejaculate.
And had a volunteer working with me.
Her name was favorite Greek Joni.
She worked with him every other day
or so for a few months and was never
successful. We were, uh,
really starting to get kind of
desperate about options and James says,
in a way it was a paradox
because on the one hand, awesome,
we have an actual living Pinta island
tortoise, but on the other hand,
he might've actually been like the
worst possible candidate for last of his
kind. He seemed to really
like to keep to himself.
He never really liked other tortoises
much. He didn't seem to like that humans.
And maybe that's why he
survived. He wasn't curious. Yes.
James says a lot of tortoises
right here, your footsteps,
they raised their heads,
they come out to see what's going
on and then they get whacked. Yeah.
In any case, for about 40 years,
scientists read everything humanly
possible to get loaned some George to meet
with another tortoise so
they could resurrect the
species and bring Pinta island
back to its original
state. Nothing worked.
[inaudible]
until one day in July of 2008.
George turns to the two female tortoises
that he had been ignoring for years.
And he says, doc,
inexplicably, he just suddenly
decides to mate with both of them,
each lay eggs.
Two clutches were ultimately laid in
his corral and the scientists are like,
George got our hopes up dramatically,
but they ultimately were in shurtell
mother
in mid eighties. They were
having a meeting about this.
That's conservation is Josh Donlin again,
whole bunch of herpetologists were out
there and some island conservationists,
and they're talking about what to do Pinta
and they can't get lonesome George to
reproduce,
which are hoping to do because then they
could build a Pinta population and put
it on panels. And he says
that as a meaning wore on,
it got tense. Oh, for sure.
In fact, one guy spoke
Harry Green.
I'm a professor of ecology and
evolutionary biology at Cornell University
said that at this meeting there was
one guy who just couldn't take it.
Oh, all I remember is him just fuming.
He sat there getting more and more
and more frustrated. Then finally,
he just blurted out, shoot
that tortoise and, uh,
quit wasting our time.
[inaudible]
because in his view this,
the single individual was holding up
this huge conservation [inaudible]
and of course the shock was there was
a way went around the room when he said
that.
I recall seeing sort of second wave as
the Spanish translation passed around the
room
and really what that guy
was specifically saying was,
don't be precious as a tourist,
as a tourist is a tortoise.
Let's just take some tortoises from a
nearby island and put them back on Pinto,
but there's a much bigger question
here that goes way beyond gloves,
which is basically like what is
the right way to protect nature?
Now people are right now throwing beers
at each other around what is the right
strategy.
Josh says that there are basically two
camps right now on the one side you've
got this classic like what you might
call Eden approach conservation biology.
It's foundation is this idea of pristine
wilderness from the very beginning.
I think all of us, well, I can't
speak for other people but,
but you always have this idea of wanting
to get it back to some kind of pre
human condition. Every human
being. The operative word and,
and if you think about it, we
all have this, we all have this,
this picture of what we want to bring it
all back to, you know, it might be like
the planes just covered with buffalo or
maybe the Serengeti desert with lions
and elephants, or maybe it's
10,000 hammerhead sharks,
but whatever the scene is
that just doesn't have any
people but is carrying that
idea, those pictures of your
head even like useful anymore.
It's like so Sanuk no, but it
just seems so unrealistic. Right?
But I mean in the bigger picture,
you can make the argument that humans
now affect every square meter of the
earth. There's no place, no
matter how remote we get,
you can go to the North Pole. It's
been affected by human activity.
You can go, I don't know, the
depths of the impenetrable jungle.
It's been affected by human activity.
That's how they dream is
she's an environmental law
professor at the Berkeley
School of law in you're
radically remaking the world.
And the question is
what's our responsibility?
And it brings us to our
second school of thought,
which in its most extreme version
goes something like this. We're God,
we might as well get good at it and
we're going to have to create these
ecosystems based on our best science.
And you could argue we're going to have
to get a whole lot better at making some
very, very difficult decisions. Climate
change seems to mean that a lot
of species are pretty much doomed,
30% 40% 50% of the species now on
the planet in a few decades maybe
disappearing. And this is what I think
is really the tough question now,
is if we can seed that we can't
any longer save all the species,
then does that put us in the situation
of having to decide which ones will save
and which ones we won't?
And do we have any basis for making
those kinds of decisions? Hmm.
So you're saying that the, that the,
let's go back to when it was good.
Let's go back to a better
time. That's just silly.
I didn't say it was silly. Okay. What
did you yeah, I said it was impossible.
Things might not be silly.
They might not be stupid ideas,
but we still might not be able to do them.
[inaudible]
okay, so here's um, a wood plaque.
It says lonesome George is the last
survivor of the dynasty of land.
Tortoise is from Pinta island and in fact
in 2012 after decades of trying to get
him to to breed
[inaudible]
lonesome,
George Dies r I p 24th of June,
2012 and the panda tortoise when extinct.
So damn case in point, I
guess. No, going back. Yeah,
I mean that's what I thought. But then
I spoke with this woman. Hello? Hello.
Just hello? Do you hear me? Yes, I do.
Who kind of scrambled everything up for
me? Can I get you to introduce yourself?
Yes. My name is [inaudible].
I am a senior research scientist at
Yale University and just tell us,
come up with kind of a radical
idea. I call it the Phoenix project.
Here's the backstory.
In the mid nineties we started in 94
to Cielo and some folks from their
Galapagos National Park.
They began taking a census of all the
tortoises in the Galapagos population of
tortoises on all the islands. They were
going to do this big population studies.
So they went island by island,
took a little bit of blood from
all these different tortoises,
did a genetic analysis and old pla
found something they never expected.
A group of tortoise is not on
Pinta that had a lot of Pinta DNA.
I remember very clearly that
moment was very, very, it's like,
yes, look at this. Yeah.
Wait, you're saying this Pinta DNA was
on a nother island? Yeah. None on Pinta.
No. Well, how would that happen?
Um, we don't think it was natural.
Gisella thinks it might've
been the whalers, either
the whalers or the pirates,
you know,
because like we talked about in the
1718 hundreds these whalers would come
along, grab a bunch of
tortoises, put them on the ship,
and then they would hunt
for whales or shoot.
And sometimes when they were done in the,
the ship was filled with whale
products. There's no room down here.
They throw a few extra
towards his overboard,
say a few from Pinta.
Maybe those pins does tortoises swim
with occurrence to that nearby island set
up a little ex-pat community and
started breeding with the locals.
That's our working hypothesis,
which brings us to [inaudible] her idea.
You know on average 50% of your genome
comes from your mom and 50% from your
dad, but it's an average.
So just sell a thought. Just by chance.
Some of these tortoises are going to have
a little bit more Pinta DNA from their
Pinta ancestors than others. Yes.
So what if we took those
tortoises and bred them together?
So back then for the next generation
so that you can give a push to this
process.
She says, if we keep doing this, taking
the babies with the most Pinta DNA,
breeding them together slowly, surely
in four generations you could have
90% of the painter genome restored.
Really? Yeah. But that's four
generations of tortoises,
not rats, which means at
least a hundred years.
But in the meantime,
the vegetation on Pinta is growing out
of control from an ecological point of
view. Pinta can't wait. So in
2009 they come up with a stop gap.
They take 39 tortoises raised in captivity
and they use them as placeholders.
They sterilize them and put them
on Pinta. Really? One day. Yeah.
Well these are very purest
sort of visions. Yeah.
They sterilize and 39 of them. They're
just basically the lawn mowers.
They're not.
Exactly and they put them on Pinta and
they're just chomping away right now.
They're living at their lives
really happily on Pinta you know,
until the originals that ready.
Now Linda says in the end
you don't actually need to
do the full aggressive for
generation breeding thing.
You can just take, I'm Jeff,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich Radiolab and this hour,
well the honeymoon's over glove vagus.
This is the place where Darwin began to
develop his theory of evolution and its
the place 170 year,
maybe 180 years later where our producer
Tim Howard landed wearing fishnets in a
bad brains tee shirt like to fight to
find a very different landscape than what
Darwin saw.
And we just told you a story about how
far humans are willing to go to protect
something. This next part,
it's about how far we're willing to go
to get something back that we've already
lost to sort of restore a place in
a creature to its quote, wild state.
This story unfolds on one of Galapagos
is most northern islands where they also
had to get rid of some goats.
It's called Pinta Pinta as was a very
special place. This is James Gibbs,
professor of conservation biology
at the State University of New York.
It's a one of those islands. It's not
part of any tourist visitation site.
So there are no people there. And
uh, when you set foot first on Pinto,
you immediately sense sheer abundance.
[inaudible]
problem is on Penna. Things
were spinning out of [inaudible]
control.
The vegetation was growing wild,
the forest was getting overgrown with
the wrong kind of plant and the whole
[inaudible]
it goes system was just
teetering out of balance.
And one of the reasons for this,
according to Linda Coyote is that we
had an island with no tortoises. Yes.
Because tortoises are sort of like
the lawnmowers, you know, they,
they plow down vegetation, disperse seeds,
but for centuries had been
hunted by those whalers,
and in about 1906 the pinta
tortoise went extinct.
1906 yeah, a little over a hundred years
ago. They don't know the exact date,
date, but then one
evening in March of 1972.